watch out down y'all
everyone put your hats on here on the
show we like to celebrate the spirit of
the holidays whenever we feel like it uh
because it's my show
so why not a random friday
i love christmas you said it insane
it was
crazy
a cluster funk christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
makes you happy happy belated hanukkah
thank you very much uh you could fit
like
30 or 40 versions of my set in this
studio
[Applause]
[Music]
okay here's your first question
what kissy kissy christmas decoration oh
come on mistletoe it is
mistletoe
[Applause]
look at that does that mean i have a
drink oh yeah yeah take yourself a drink
girl come on
oh no it's only when you well go ahead
just have a drink anyway
there you go
come on bullock
name all nine of santa's reindeer oh
you know dasher and dancer and prancer
and vixen comet and cupid and donner and
blitzen and then rudolph right that's it
50 billion points
unbelievable
you don't have to do it
[Applause]
the truth is kelly clarkson can i call
you kelly yes can i call you clarky
no the truth is clarky
i never really felt like i belonged oh
well wait let's try some free
association um i'll tell you all the
things i think are wonderful about
christmas and you can tell me your you
know your opinions of them how about
that well i thought we were close to a
breakthrough but okay
all right um well being with loved ones
you know like friends in whoville
all that togetherness oh
it's highly overrated ew
interesting okay
okay um well all the beautiful holiday
decorations oh an absolute eyesore
someone should call the authorities
gaudy
well art is subjective um talking in
rhymes should be a crime i mean illegal
illegal a new jersey woman has amassed
nearly two million tick tock followers
with her off the cuff commentary on
holiday foods
yep all she does is throw some christmas
music under a video of food being
prepared and react to it it's awesome
the one i'm about to show you artie has
9.6 million views and i'm humbled to say
that i have a small role check this out
for the rest of the year is to be kelly
clarkson what are we making a long to
celebrate and we'll sing this together
and then what happened kelly one day
what happened kelly everything changed
it's a tree and there's snow and i love
it a cubby cake
i love that she can't be bothered in
this whole thing that i love her so much
kate's christmas wish is coming true
because we have her on the line right
now
[Applause]
i love your sweater you're so honored to
finally be meeting the christmas queen
[Applause]
so you've done i just found out is it 19
hallmark movies
that's crazy
that's a lot of work you're rocking it
you're getting you're killing it dude i
know i've had it really good
comes that time of year if you say you
don't like christmas i'm gonna smith no
listen
tell me if i'm lying we record
every hallmark christmas movie every
year and watch every one of them oh my
god i'm pleased
we've watched every movie you've ever
made yes no i'm
[Music]
[Applause]
you open a gift from your grandma in
front of the whole family only to
realize
it's a sexy
toy huh
do you
uh i like how you said sexy do you it's
because i thought of something funny
what would you do though if you got a
weird gift like that in front of your
grandma in front but did she give it to
me or did she oh is i missed the
question wait you're damaged you're
grabbing your grandma
i totally read it and didn't even i
thought you were just opening it
get it grandma
i feel like i would be proud see yeah
all right see i don't know
yeah but
that's an awkward question we should
maybe take out
i just got it
it's like wow you were discretionary
kelly clarkson
properly i know i thought it was just
triple
awkward in front of your grandma i
totally read it and didn't actually
batteries included
this is where machines and humanity
emerge
that is happy holidays
and humanity emerge that isn't that the
best slogan for the matrix um and that's
the chris matrix spirit
oh my god all right we are back and
today we're kicking off something very
special we've asked you our viewers to
grab your pilot g2 gelling pins the
go-to pin of the kelly clarkson show and
write us a letter telling us about a
real-life santa that you know we're
talking about humans who overachieve and
spreading the holiday spirit our first
letter actually comes from the mayor of
mckinney texas
and he's in love texas and he's in the
audience so let's say hi to mayor george
fuller everybody
i have watched you on christmas i've
been there with you as you give out
presents and and
clothes and toys and shoes to kids that
otherwise would not get them and i've
watched them uh the the smiles on their
face and i'm telling you that is
something they're going to take with
them the rest of their lives and you are
better thank you so much i'm so very
grateful oh i'm so proud of you jackson
you are today's real life santa and that
comes with more than just praise
well-deserved praise on my dad pilot g2
gelling pin is designed for
overachievers just like you and that's
why pilot is using their pin to write
never too young to care a check for five
thousand dollars how's that sound oh my
god
she's now amassed over 3500 santas all
carefully set up and a makeshift museum
inside her alabama home over the years
she's had hundreds of people come to
visit and bask in the magic of her
collection we have anita on the line
right now hi anita
hey kelly oh my gosh it looks so magical
where you are i wish i was there in
person it's nice to meet you you must
really love santa
i do it brings such joy and cheer to
people men women and children
and my children believe in santa
and they're in their 50s i told them
when they were little if you don't
believe in santa you don't get nothing
from santa claus
so
ladies what's your take on holiday
hallmark movies y'all in you'll want
you'll love them i mean the 31 days
i've been watching them nightly my
favorite is the potato snow that is like
so obviously not snow and it's like shot
in like the valley so it's hot
and they're sweating but they're all
like in the snow it's my favorite oh my
gosh my mother and scissors says they
love it they never miss one
[Music]
today
[Music]
you